[Music]
well good evening several weeks today
fresh from his knockout win over dillian
why in front of 94 000 spectators at
wembley the heavyweight champion of the
world tyson fury looked me and looked
you in the eye and announced to the
world he was not going to fight again
well let me tell you something pierce
morgan uncensored this is the truth the
gospel truth nothing but the truth i'm
done
you know every good dog has its day and
like the great roman leader said
there'll always be somebody else to
fight when is enough enough i'm happy
i'm healthy i've still got my brains i
can still talk i've got a beautiful wife
i've got six kids i've got obtained
belts i've got plenty of money success
fame glory
what what more am i doing it for
well this morning in the sun newspaper
tyson gave a little hint
that it may not be
completely out of the question that he
might come out of a time for a reported
200 million pound fight to unify all the
titles so what's changed i'm glad to say
that tyson is joining me with the
beautiful wife paris that he talked
about in our last interview good evening
to both of you
good evening pierce hello there now
tyson i've got one question to ask you
when you looked me in the eye
those weeks ago yeah you vowed you were
never ever going to fight again
did you mean it
yeah
yes
yeah
so you're not gonna fight again
no i still mean it piss
so when you're not gonna be fighting any
more professional fights i'm finished
what happens if the joshua yousick fight
in august in saudi arabia is a bit of a
thriller and joshua wins
and the jungle drums begin beating that
the whole of britain wants to see you
finally getting a ring with anthony
joshua and frank warren being the
brilliant promoter that he is
puts a check on the table in front of
you
for such a gargantuan summer money you
think you know what i've got one bit of
unfinished business and it's joshua
no you know i don't care who wins out
the fight i wish i'm both luck in the
world
um i'm done i told you i was done seven
weeks ago i meant it there's some talk
of me having some exhibition fights but
to be honest with you i can't see that
coming off either um because i've got no
real interest in fighting anymore um
it's not just the fight on the night
it's all the stuff in the gym taking
punches to the head
it's just enough is enough for me um i
put a ridiculous number on today i said
i'll come back for half a billy half a
billion pounds that's 500 million so if
that's not ridiculous
ridiculous enough to believe i'm not
coming back for boxing i don't know what
it is but somebody i'm franklin warren
is a good person
somebody might get
somebody might get that number for you
they might get that number for you if
they do
if they do if they say
here's half a billion would you take it
yeah
listen i would definitely look at it if
there's half a billion on the table just
look at it
just have a look so
paris not going to see it
for billy well let me come to your wife
who i suspect you know probably wears
the the rings in this in this marriage
paris
how would you feel because i know after
the wilder trilogy he vowed he wasn't
going to fight again and you well you
believed him and he did then fight again
well after the first fight
yeah do you think he means his first
fight wilder i begged him not to fight
again and then he obviously fought on
and he had the trilogy and then he's
fought again just the other day in
wembley and he says he's definitely
quitting and he's definitely finishing
on top but
there's just still a glint in his eyes
that i see
and i just i just don't know i'd like
him to retire everybody in his family
we're all happy with everything he's
done and he's just obviously he's done
amazing but
i just
don't know there's something in the back
of my mind that thinks tyson's still
itching for certain fights he's saying
this
we're here honestly this is why and he
tells me no and i would love to believe
it
but i'm just not quite there i think i'm
with the rest of the public thinking is
it true you see paris this is why i
wanted you in this interview because the
wives always know tyson if it was just
me and you i'd be taking all this at
face value but the woman you love
who you live with who knows you better
than any person alive
she sees that glint in your eye
and she thinks there's unfinished
business
okay i'll ask her a question while
you're on paris yeah do you want me to
fight again for any amount of money no
yes or no no 100 million or 200 million
change our lives not at all but when
have you done what i've asked you to do
he always does what he wants to do he
will only do what he wants to do whether
it pleases me him or everybody he's only
going to do what he wants to do and what
if i said i'm not going to fight i said
warren i've told bob arum i've told
everybody tyson fury and fighting
is finished
the money is not tempting to me to be
fair
um
but there's something still calling you
out there because the other day you were
saying oh i want to do expeditions i
don't i might do this and i might do
that you train every day like a crazy
trojan yeah but i do train for mental
health and emotional fitness and
everything else but the fact of the
matter is
i might might do an exhibition
exhibitions are not real fights to just
pretend play time showtime entertainment
but there's still something calling you
there and i just wonder you never know i
i hope you retired and i hope it stays
that way but it's one of them
we'll wait and see it
i'll have to wait do i have to stay out
the ring before i'm officially retired
then i don't know i think he was retired
for 10 minutes on box rep wasn't he
but i have been out the ring before for
three years
three years and i came back tyson
never but it so i said we're just gonna
we've got a slight issue with your
microphone so i'm gonna talk to paris
and we're going to go full screen with
paris here while we fix your mic and
then we'll come back because paris
parish is actually doing a brilliant job
on my behalf getting the truth out of
you so we're going to come just to paris
for a moment apparently yeah
and we're going to fix tyrus's might
while we do okay so paris here's
what i want to talk to you about you
first met tyson when you when you were
what age
uh 15 15 years old 15 i was pierced
you've had a remarkably uh long
successful not always perfect marriage
to somebody who is i think one of the
most unique people i've ever met in
sport
uh uniquely smart uniquely fascinating
uh you know had his troubles always talk
so openly about them what's it been like
to be with tyson all this time and how
have you seen him evolve
um tyson has always been up and down and
always been this crazy lovable person
that he is
and he's evolved in the fact that i
think he's matured which i do think all
men take a little bit longer to do and
he is now
happy and content in his life and i
think that's why he's retired i think
that's why in his heart and soul he's
happy with everything he's done and the
career went great everything that he
ever wanted to do and told me all them
years ago even as a young boy at 15 or
16 he told me i'm going to be
heavyweight champ of the world i didn't
really believe it i didn't didn't
believe that he couldn't do it i just
thought he'd probably get picked up in
other things um but tyson has done it
and i think he's happy and contented
which has made our life just brilliant
and everything's running really well
we've got six healthy children we're
happy and were doing great so to tick
all the boxes he's done that
and
he's contented with his career and his
life of what he's done but
as the wife i just
i just look and i just wonder are you
doing as much as everyone else and i
hope he is i hope that with like
boxing's done and he chooses another
path and finds something that he's
passionate about and carries on with it
but
will he stay out the ring i honestly and
we're sitting here together and whatever
whatever we say afterwards but i do
think there's a question mark there
i do too we're going to take a short
break when we come back i'll be back to
you tyson with some more tough questions
welcome back to peterborough since it is
round two with tyson paris fury
so i know that we've got you back on a
on a proper mic again which is good we
can hear you loud and clear so look your
wife's having none of this she sees the
glint she thinks there's unfinished
business
and i'm with paris on this
yep are you with a lot of other people
as well it's me dad my lawyer my wife
well me and the lawyer have a bet don't
we yeah i i i just think i'm the only
person who actually believes in what i'm
saying you know a lot of people say no
tyson fury doesn't know when he's
telling the truth himself but you know
the word can be me bond and it can be
tried and tested the future will will
tell if i'm telling the truth or not how
about this how about given if you do
fight again you're going to get a barrel
load of
cash
gazillions how about if you do fight
again you have to give me a million
pounds
how about that's a deal
really can i join in on that yeah you
have a million pounds as well paris so
we have a deal do we you'll give me a
million quid if you fight if i'm getting
half a billion yeah exactly yeah i'll
give you a million quid i'll get paris
one two all right so if you haven't half
a billion from me fighting won't matter
will it all right so paris and i will
get a million pounds each if you fight
again
yeah 100
i love that deal because i've got a
feeling we're going to cash in paris
what's a million pounds
like me can you please remind me
tyson i have to now apologize for your
bad language you're a very naughty boy
oh
i thought this was uncensored here's
morgan
still early it's not that unsensitive
tyson let me ask you hypothetically if
you were to fight again if
the fight was going to be say in saudi
arabia you know all the fuss that's
going on currently with this sports
washing as they call it and particularly
about the golfers you've taken money to
play in a saudi-backed tournament what
do you feel about that i i personally i
wrote a column today for the new york
post fantastic
sorry we've gone yeah that's a fantastic
question pierce
because isn't our own government trying
to strike a deal with the saudi saudi to
get a better oil and gas rate at the
moment yes
as are the americans so how can anyone
say anything
about a sports deal when everybody's
clamoring to saudi to get a better deal
on oil prices well this is what i wrote
in my column for the new york post i
think there's so much hypocrisy around
this you know you've got the next world
cup coming this autumn in qatar for
example you know formula one has races
in saudi arabia a lot of uh sporting
bodies do business with china huge
business with china which also has a
polling record of human rights i guess
my question for you
do you feel there should be any moral
line is there any way you wouldn't feel
comfortable
fighting
you know for me pierce i can only take
people as i find them
and no matter what somebody else says
about you
i will judge you on the way you are with
me
and i would like to think you would do
that with me yeah so no matter what
anybody else says about your pierce i
like you
[Laughter]
but
i i only take people as i find them you
know what i'm saying i'm the same
so i don't listen to rumors and all that
stuff all the rubbish that goes with it
i take people on face value on how they
are as as people would be and if i
haven't had any dealings with these
people i can't really have a comment
does that make sense i think it makes
perfect sense and i think the whole
sport watching thing is riddled with
hypocrisy let me ask you tyson when you
when i i just literally got pissed hey
so
go on go on go on continue no no you're
the champion i think it's only
it's yeah it's only like oh it's a big
scene when it's it's not the right
person who's doing it if it's the
government who's doing oil and gas deals
it's fine if it's the sports star making
a fortune it's bad
you know i don't know where it all all
ends on all stars it's like what's good
for one is good for the gander sports
for the full world sport shouldn't be
just for one country or anywhere else
this you shouldn't discriminate anybody
that's right sports is for the world to
see
together that's what it's all about i
i absolutely agree i think it's all
completely hypocritical the whole debate
if governments are prepared to treat
these countries like saudi arabia as
allies and buy oil and trade arms with
them i don't think that sportsmen should
be held to this kind of ferocious
account for their supposed immorality if
this is what their own governments are
doing all the time um let me ask you uh
tyson
about
uh love because you're a passionate man
you're an emotional man and you've got
this beautiful woman that has been with
you since you were both very young what
has been the secret of your
romance together
i think i'm very qualified to speak on
the matter of love because
i've been married 13 nearly 14 years
this year started as kids together from
15 16
6 kids and all that so yeah i think
love is a fantastic um
thing if you can ever find love in your
life whether it's you're loving someone
or you have a love for something
it's a fantastic fantastic thing and
someone who's never experienced love can
have the world but they'll have nothing
how do you love affair with like sports
and me
yeah i mean tyson have you have you ever
been in love with anybody else or has
paris been the one always for you
paris has been my first love and only
love as in a person
but i have
i've had a
a really vicious
love affair
keep going we're boxing on and off my
whole life
paris when you hear
paris when you hear this this this man
mounted this this world heavyweight
champion this all-time great of the
sport when you hear him being so
romantic
how does it make you feel
do you know what peace you've got to
take in fact that tyson's just my
husband it's not heavyweight champ it's
not nothing special like yes i can
credit him and say he's done really well
but the end of the day me and him has
just been together for being kids and
i don't look at him in that light so for
him to say that i think well yeah that's
good that's lovely of course a husband
should love his wife and vice versa you
should love the person you're with you
should love your partner no matter what
so that's obviously a bit given isn't it
you can't really be with someone if you
don't want to be with them and you don't
love them and paris what are the best i
don't look at it later it's one of these
big fighters
what are the best and worst things about
tyson from a wife's perspective
be honest now because we're on the pace
morgan show we're here to tell the truth
the truth is uncensored the bestest
thing is house yeah
is how
crazy and
spontaneous
and
outgoing and
talkative and everything he has with him
that's the greatest side of him
and then that's also the worst side of
him because that has two sides of the
table you've got the great sides of like
right come on we're going somewhere
today and everything's happy but then
you've got the the other side that's
like hey wake up come on get up get
packed i want to leave i'm going to
china tonight so you've got the good and
the bad and
i i don't know i can't say the bad or
the good tyson's obviously had his ups
and downs and we've been through it all
together so
we're just through it through thick and
thin aren't we i just sound you're a
fantastic i think you're a fantastic
couple i do i i've and i know it's not
she's like my ride ride or die
she's my ride or die chick piss
let me ask she's the one when i do the
bank robbery she's driving the car
let me ask you tyson when i did
celebrity apprentice in america uh with
lennox lewis we were we were stuck
together for about six weeks and became
good friends and i've got a lot of time
for lennox but he told me when he was
the heavyweight champion the world when
he used to go out clubbing especially in
sort of new york and so on
the biggest guy in every place they went
at some stage of the night would come
and try it on want to have a fight
do you get that
yeah
do you know what great question no i
don't get it anywhere because i don't
walk around like i'm a heavyweight
champion in the world i've not got a
chip on my shoulder and my aura is come
here while i give you a hug and sing you
was hung my auras not let me punch you
in the face i'm a tough guy so never
once in my whole life yeah i can vouch
for that i've never ever seen it no one
has ever approached me for a fight or
approached me in aggressive manner no
because i'm not that i've not got that
aura or edge on me where i need to prove
myself or whatever you're not like
aggressive macho man are you no i'd
rather just sing and dance and have a
beer and whatever else well i'll tell
you why i was asking because um as you
may have seen
the books of julius francis who actually
fought mike tyson um he was he's now
he's now doing security and he got into
this incident a couple of days ago just
show a little clip this is a box park at
wembley
[Applause]
now it's interesting he's
they aren't going to charge him with
anything for this even though you're not
the guy out i watched the whole video
this guy was abusing julius francis
abusing everybody else and eventually he
looked like he was threatening julius
francis and julius chin did what did you
make of that
yeah
you know
all of it i saw the video i've seen it
i've seen the knockout great right hand
by the way um
but you know this is what happens when
you're cheeky rude getting in people's
faces punching them whatever what do you
expect
if you keep kicking a dog it's going to
bite you isn't it
and you know these guys are there doing
a job there wasn't all on the lash
together
this guy's probably pissed off or
whatever had a few drinks
get cheeky these guys are doing their
job he's attacking them whatever so he's
been chinned
um
and that's a life lesson
never go out and be cheeky to big men
because you're probably gonna get
chinned
i love the fact uh tyson
well other fact you said he'd rather
sing because i recently interviewed as
you know don mclean the great uh
american singer-songwriter who gave us
american pie here's what don mclean said
about you after you gave us that kind
message
i was gonna tell tyson i love to meet
him someday i love him
he is what boxing has needed um he is a
lovable champion and he's a great
champion and i wanted to tell him
that um whenever i get in trouble now
i'm going to say that i have him as my
best friend and i'm going to warn
anybody who's trying to mess with me
that i have him on speed dial you know
what i mean
what do you think of that tyson
i said don's a great guy i only spoke to
him yesterday on instagram he said he's
over in the uk november december so i
said let's hang out and have a beer so
this is crazy i'm going to be having a
beer with don mclean i'm probably
singing uh a version of american pie
together again well let's see yeah the
american pie song that was released
recently
featuring myself and don yeah it's um
it's won a load of awards so yeah do you
feel like giving us a little burst now
title someone that can't really sing
what would you like to wear i'd like to
hear a bit of american pie please
so bye
bye miss american pie drove my chevy to
the levee but the levee was dry
them good old boys were drinking whiskey
and right
singing this will be the day that i die
i've heard this song so many times
this is like the ongoing anthem in our
house the kids even sing it now i love
it you know i absolutely love those
songs piss
do you know what is crazy though
like everyone keeps telling tyson you're
a great singer a great singer now he's
good he's okay but they're actually
offering him record songs now record
labels are coming to him and offering
him songs and albums
he can't sing what are you doing well i
was listening to these who was listening
to this song i i'm a bit of a
bit of a negative one on that one she's
negative on that one now paris on a more
positive note there are rumors swirling
that there may be another addition to
the fury household can you say anything
about that
ah i've heard about these rumors for
about
four two months now
and shall we just clarify yeah you can
it ain't true oh
i've heard this for months and i keep
leaving it and i keep thinking where are
they going to wake up i have lost a good
bit of weight recently i'm feeling
pretty body proud
and it's like everyone keeps saying
she's pregnant she's pregnant no no no
we've got six and we're happy with that
number right now well you look fantastic
and tyson as you know you are batting
away put it this way pace yes we will
have another child before i fight again
i'm really not six that's a guaranteed
fact well i've got listen if you fight
again i've got my million quid coming my
way uh but tyson i think you would
accept that you aren't good me too
to use the the the vernacular phrase
tyson you are punching way above your
weight i think you'd agree right
oh
thank you very much pierce he won't
agree because he's he's a he's a very
competitive guy that'll never happen
he'll never agree
i agree my wife is is she's fantastic
she's had six kids she's that's alive
she's probably had about ten that we've
lost a few as well along the way
she is a full-time mother housewife
everything
she's the best-selling author
she does so many things and she looks
fantastic so you know
i've done all right
i used to look good when i had hair and
all i bought now i'm like the beast from
the east
the big old ugly ball did it fella oh i
make up with it uh pierce in character
in character
in my character i look like brad pitt
uh i've got to mention your talk i could
talk to you guys all night but sadly i
have to leave it there you've got a new
talk coming fury fest the official after
party tour it would include a meet and
greet with with you with a q a and more
the first day i think is this friday in
london tickets are on sale now give me a
quick um sort of early preview of what
it's about tyson
it's you know it's about the the boxing
career it's the mental health um story
it's everything you know give people an
opportunity to come and sit down and
listen maybe they're suffering with
mental health for self maybe they're
having boxing funds or maybe they just
want a fantastic night so if you haven't
got tickets already get tickets there's
only 16 shows on the first leg um and
i'm selling out really quick so get
yours right now brilliant tyson paris
what a pleasure to talk to you both
really loved it you were both gloriously
uncensored please come back again soon
it's always great to have you on the
show
thanks very much peace for always having
us on you are the best and you're
watching piss morgan on sensor
guitar
i love it chad i love it
great to talk to you both all the time
bye guys
bye now bye-bye thank you
brilliant
absolutely brilliant i love tysonfield i
love paris fury what a wonderful couple
aren't they
uh brilliant
you